now we're gonna do the second kind now I
was interesting it's actually very
clever I didn't tell you to do this but
when you went out there if you are doing
the compass radio server instead of the
UM the plane table the line-of-sight one
essentially this is all you're doing
you're getting some bearings you're
sending someone to walk off and then on
that bearing you then get a distance so
this is the essential butter I'm going
to take this and I'm going to convert it
into a radio cermony
so just as I was walking around I saw
the vast majority diagrams were much too
small so if you're doing this one from
scratch with me
do it at least half your page you could
even conceivably
do your whole page on this because
there's lots of information we're gonna
fit on but I'm just going to imagine
that's my opinion okay now if you were
doing compass bearing I highly suggested
that you send someone walking off in the
North direction because that makes
everything easier to orient you don't
have to but if you send them off in
random directions you just got to make
sure you keep every constraint we do
have north at zero degrees true so I'm
going to Marian from the center and I'm
just gonna roll that straight
so this is my person who's going north I
have made measured out sixty meters then
I've got someone who went sixty degrees
and you can see I have got them listed
actually a slightly different water from
the water I saw I've got this listed
going in which direction doing it this
way or do I go that way it's clockwise
so I'm going to go sixty degrees
I think that's roughly and that's gonna
be 39 minutes I'm going to keep going
all the way around until I've done all
of my measurements
okay now this next step I'm about to do
is pretty much identical to the way we
did it before I'm gonna look at my
longest length which on this it looks
like if 70 minutes is that rifle Marines
70 is the longest one you measure yeah
and I'm gonna choose that and use my
scale now what I'm gonna do at this
point is last time I gave you nice easy
numbers right
I went 70 meters become 17 millimeters
and that's nice and convenient but
sometimes you can't fit that onto your
diagram right so I'm gonna show you how
it works if it's a little more
complicated suppose I look at this 17
minute distance okay I put my ruler
against there and I can fit 70
millimeters it fits but I'd like it to
be bigger okay it's in your interest to
choose a relatively nice simple number
if it's one to one that's great
suppose I can fit ten and a half
centimeters now maybe you're not
thinking ten and a half centimeters is
an obvious length but if you take the
number seven and if you multiply it by
one point five then you should get well
what's half of seven half of seven is
three and a half so one and a half
sevens is ten point five okay so on the
bottom of you what I'm going to write is
70 meters in reality it becomes what I
just say 10 a 105 millimeters I'll stick
a stick with millimeters because own
that keeps everything whole numbers
rather than decimal points so can you
see what do I do to transform this
number into this number I change the
units meters into millimeters and then I
also multiply by what number what did
you say 1.5 okay so I'm going to use
that for all of them
x 1.5 together so this is a ten point
five centimeter line on my page then see
this sixteen right I'm going here from
16 it is I'm going to multiply by one
point five and that'll give me a new
language on my and that should be 16
times 1.5 what's successful Quebec
that's ninety right so I'm going to
measure a 19 millimeter mine yeah so all
I did was I looked at my longest land
and I want to fit onto the page so I
pick a length here that gives me a nice
neat number right so if I could it
before example if I could fit a 140
millimeter lion PR of a page then I'd
use that because I just double that's
really easy but maybe your page is not
big enough
you can't fit 140 on there so I can fit
a hundred five millimeters so I chose
that it's still relatively easy to work
with it if that makes sense as a number
that number is easy to work so if yours
was say 19 millimeters that the figures
line you could choose there you could
make it 19 I can show you that in a
second
but I would probably choose 70
millimeters because there's 70 meters
easily converts into seven millimeters
so you can choose whatever size one
choose an easy one choose a nice easy
number and then it minimizes the working
yeah that's exactly correct
well you divide everything by thousand
which was what changes the unit's you're
mean to me that makes me so now I'm just
going to do the rest of them so I said
that this is 60 meters it's going to
become 290 millimeters so I'll just
measure that off
39 I'll multiply that by running a half
what is that
five yes all major whatever that is and
then I'm going to do that whoops it is
all the way around
okay so here's my tango now that's where
the plane table radio survey when we did
by line-of-sight and the compass radio
survey this is where they become
different okay the line of sight one we
don't really expect you to get any
accuracy particularly on where the
angles are but this time you use the
compass to do it okay so what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna look at my diagram
and notice I've made a bunch of
triangles do you see I had fine lines so
I've got a pistol in the middle here do
you see the Pentagon do you notice that
the Pentagon is made up of five
triangles one two three four five and in
each one I can work out with the angles
like for instance have a look at this
angle in here the first one I drew it
goes from zero degrees to true to 60
degrees
sure right that's what I wrote down so
humor me what's the size of that angle
from 0 to 60 takes just 60 right that's
the easiest one the rest of them not so
easy
I went from 60 to 150 that's gonna be a
right angle like that yeah that was
convenient
that's one from 150 to 190 40 you should
be mark amazing on your diagram 192 240
that's 50 and then what's the last
angles 240 is going to go all the way to
a full revolution which is 360 so the
difference is 120 okay now we've got a
lot of angles we've got a lot of legs
this part that we're going to do next is
not especially fun but it does afford us
a lot more accuracy than just the line
of sight last time we used the scale
here we just put our ruler up and we
just measure this length remember that
and then we converted whatever but now
they know an actual measurement another
actual measurement and this angle here
which is also measured with a compass in
this triangle here I could use the
cosine rule I can use trade okay so
let's label these um let's label these
lengths let's give them names so I'm
going to call this a B C D and E so just
have a look up in this first triangle
let me let me draw the first triangle
separately just so you can see it but we
won't do it again for the rest of
Kentucky Pro the first triangle looks
like this
there's another topic since maybe enough
density a big deposit is gonna do with
the movie after like a few most like to
say that I assure you the question
tonight okay so can you see that this is
what I've done is I've just taken this
one triangle and I've just ripped it out
okay this big radio survey is just made
up a bunch of triangles which by the way
is one of the reasons why we spend time
with trigonometry pretty much every
shape in the world you can break any
trusses and I'm trying to work out this
guy over here okay this is the cosine
rule I've got two sides and though which
I go is that all it's the included angle
very good so I'm gonna use the cosine
rule now the cosine rule is it's like
Pythagoras that's souped up do you
remember that so it's going to be sixty
quick square plus thirty nine squared
right very good - to lots of
the 60 x 39 that's a and B and it's
because I drool so it finishes with
clothes of 60 degrees so by the way
there's a real thing here right this is
what psychologists called chunking that
when I think of the cosine rule I think
of this because I just used it so much
and you guys will use it a lot so you'll
get there too
I think of this as one object not
there's like ten different objects so
that's why it's easier for me to
remember I just remember one thing in
exactly the same way that I don't know
how many of you want to saw this video
but if I gave you a list of numbers
right I want you to try and remember
this difference let me show you okay the
list numbers is 7 1 0 2 3 0 3 now you
can memorize that list of numbers you
can work this out if I give you 30
seconds to look at it and then cover it
up I reckon you can recite it to me but
it would take some mental effort do you
agree like okay I've got the numbers in
order however if I just write it like
this you're like oh that's not 8
different numbers that's one object it's
today's date right so now gotcha so now
do you see this is eight chunks this is
eight chunks but this is one chunk
that's so much easier to remember right
you're not holding you can barely like
remember what you're what gave a
breakfast while you're thinking about
this but here yeah that's why it's today
right so it's the same thing for this
with time with time this becomes one
object in your head as opposed to a
whole bunch but before you get there
just
okay can you help me out let's work out
what all of this is you get a number out
which is oops which is a square can you
tell me what this number is that you get
there just go ahead say that again okay
but of course that can't be the leg
that's ridiculous because it's the leg
squared so I'm going to take the square
root of both sides excuse me can I get
one too so nice few T 2.7 okay now like
I said it is not particularly enjoyable
but the way that you now work out this
perimeter is you have to continue doing
this all the way around with a new
triangle each time it's not fun however
it is vastly more accurate than doing it
just by line of sight because you can't
have any confidence in your angles
really with line of sight you just have
a rough idea okay